ist es ihr wirklich egal beim besuch
eines heims für kinder illegaler
einwanderer an der grenze zu mexiko
sorgt first lady melania trump für
aufsehen aber weniger mit ihrem dortigen
auftritt sondern mit der jacke die sie
auf dem weg dorthin trägt beim besteigen
des flugzeugs in richtung texas trägt
melania einen parka mit der aufschrift
we don t you
zu deutsch es ist mir völlig egal und
die online sorgt der spruch für allerlei
gesprächsstoff sind die migrantenkinder
der first lady egal hat es das falsche
teil und strand ergriffen ist es eine
versteckte botschaft melania sprecherin
widerspricht den spekulationen die
medien sollten sich auf den besuch der
first lady an der us-grenze anstatt auf
ihre jacke fokussieren eine versteckte
botschaft gebe es nicht us präsident
donald trump nimmt seine ehefrau
ebenfalls in schutz
der spruch beziehe sich auf die fake
news medien twitter trump melania hat
gelernt wie unehrlich sie sind und es
ist ihr inzwischen wirklich egal
die jacke soll ein preisgünstiges modell
von der stange sein an sich ungewöhnlich
für das frühere model das gerne
exquisite garderobe trägt auch das trägt
zu den anhaltenden spekulationen bei
zumal es nicht das erste mal ist
melanie a tramp mit ihrer kleiderwahl
für stirnrunzeln sorgt 2017 stärkste sie
auf extrem hochhackigen und in schuhen
durch das texanische houston um die
vorherigen harry angerichteten
verwüstungen zu besichtigen
[Musik]